- It is also craft week.
And we have a crochet designer
who's been crocheting since the age of 13
and a business owner since the age of 15.
And she's joining us from Philadelphia.
Hey, CBS 3, by the way.
Please welcome Emani Outterbridge
(audience applauding)
- Hi Drew.
- Hi Emani.
- Hi Drew. Hi ya.
- Okay, I have to tell you,
I am freaking out about
your business model.
It is the coolest thing I've ever seen.
Take a look at this,
you created the world's
first yarn vending machine.
- [Emani] Yes, I did. I did.
- I mean, and now you have
multiple of them in Philadelphia.
Your business is expanding.
Cardi B has worn one of your designs.
Emani, are you up for a challenge,
to make something throughout the show
and maybe create a little
piece by the time we're done?
Yes, Drew, please challenge me.
I'm up for anything.
Please challenge me.
- Okay Emani, we're gonna do that.
And we're gonna check in with you
throughout the whole
show, and keep chatting.
- All right, that's fine.
- Okay, thanks Emani, so much.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
And I wanted to check in with Emani.
How's it going?
- It's going fine, Drew. Almost done.
- [Drew] Oh my gosh, it's beautiful.
And that's my favorite color.
- Yeah, they told me you love yellow.
- It's true.
It's our signature color of the show.
What are you making?
- A bikini.
- [Drew] Oh, no way!
- Yes.
- Oh my God! All right.
I'm gonna go on a diet right now.
(everyone laughing)
Emani, you're so amazing.
I'm gonna check back in
with you and I want to know,
how and why you started your business.
I'll be right back with you.
- Probably in the news break.
- [Emani] Okay.
Thank you, Emani. You're so beautiful.
Let's check in with our intrepid
crochet designer, Emani,
who's been crocheting something special
for us throughout the show.
Emani, how's it going?
- It's going, it's going.
We're almost done.
- [Drew] Okay, I'm so excited.
I'm gonna check back in with you
in the next segment and see you again.
Emani, how's it going?
I'm checking in with you.
We're almost out of time.
- We're all done.
Here's the bottom, and here's the top.
Oh, Emani, you are so amazing.
And if you want to go to our website,
we're going to feature Emani's website.
'Cause you starting a business at 15,
you have so much to teach people.
Thank you so much for
being on the show today.
And to all of our Veteran
friends and family today,
honored, honored to
spend this time with you.
Please take this with you for the rest
of this most important Veteran's Day.
We'll see you soon.
Cheers.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat theme music)